we begin in rwanda where one woman is
facing two years in jail for what
authorities call indecent dressing
lilian mugabe was arrested in early
august after a photo of her wearing a
transparent dress in public went viral
police then held her for 12 days until
she was granted bail a court hearing is
expected soon
this is the dress liliane mugabe kazi
wore to a concert in rwanda's capital
kigali
after this photo went viral she was
accused of shameful dressing and
arrested
now the 24 year old has been charged
with public indecency and could face
prison sparking a debate on social media
and across rwanda
i can't say she was unfairly arrested i
followed lillian's issue she was wearing
a transparent garment and a short coat
those are clothes
that make men sexually aroused awakening
satan
that is not nudity nudity for me is when
there is no garment whatsoever on your
body
imagine someone left her home feeling
well dressed in that outfit but you
decide to attack her simply because you
have failed to control your sexual
desires
but other rwandan women are not
impressed with mugabe kazi's choice of
outfit
uh
as a rwandan woman
who understands rwandan values
of respecting oneself and others
i would say
that the dress wasn't respectable
public indecency is a crime punishable
by up to two years in jail but there's
confusion over what it actually means
the law itself doesn't define what is
public in this sense
so that means um
it's it's subject to interpretation
while a parallel
a good one should not be i mean should
not give room for interpretation it
should be precise clear
to everyone
the case is also causing concern over
what it could mean for rwanda's fashion
and entertainment industries and even
for women who wear miniskirts when they
go out
liliane mugabe kazi meanwhile is out on
bail waiting for a court to decide if
she'll be sent to jail for her choice of
outfit
let's speak now to juliet carrie tanyi a
women's rights activist in rwanda she
joins us from kigali it's good to have
you on the program juliet now you've
seen the images of lilian mugabe was
that an appropriate outfit to wear in
public
it was an appropriate outfit to wear at
a concert if i may see she went to a
concert
and that's a an outfit that is trendy so
as a young person she was in her right
to where she wanted
a lot of people saying that was indecent
because it exposed
um her body was it was transparent so so
what would you say to them
uh indecency
depends on people it's very um
like depends and uh i wouldn't say that
it was even in public because this one
was in a closed room and because of the
media and the person who took her
picture uh without consent definitely
and that's why we got to see her but if
we were in in the age where there were
no camera we couldn't even heard about
her how would you define indecency
uh to me personally and that's why i say
personally indecency would be
someone going
out really naked with no clothes on
in public as in on the road and
where so many people are
in the market
and may also people maybe are making out
in public that's indecisive to me but
having someone who's
had like
who's wearing something something that
they want and they shopped
in and it's really something they want
it's not indecency
so so you're saying this is a kind of
a personal interpretation of it so who
really should define
indecency is it the individual is it the
government or society how should this
work
every society view things differently
and uh miranda also has many people
or those who are conservative and those
who aren't and and because um there is a
law that is
that does not have more detail and leave
people to interpret it differently it
could be great to have um details of
what is indecency and if there isn't
then the whole law should be repealed
and i think it's something that we need
to do as soon as possible because i see
a lot of discrimination towards women
than men we see many men who go topless
in concerts uh we see many men going
even on the road and it's taken normally
as something that is normal but women's
body are being sexualized and uh that's
why i think she faced a lot of
a lot of backlash and this is a mindset
that is rooted in patriarchy in religion
where we see a lot of backlash being um
towards women than than men and i think
that's what happened to yen
okay juliet carrie tany communications
specialist and women's rights activist
in kigali thank you for speaking to us
thank you for having me